bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi domeniche quindi
come asso come ogni [ __ ] domenica che
si rispetti siamo su e per la mia gioia
possiamo fare una puntata un pochettino
speciale di è più visto dopo tutte
queste fottute puntate 20 ragazzi ha
deciso di fare una puntata un pochettino
speciale questa volta deciso di fare una
specie di momenti epici di happy visco
si parla chiudere i momenti più
divertenti solo ed esclusivamente di
equi quindi ragazzi spero che mi piace
stracchino che cazzo paese ha vinto ha
vinto lui a caso bravo addominale amico
mio e lo dico anche i ragazzi voglio
voglio provarci perché prima ci sono
riuscito suor trovo di provare adesso
[Musica]
se è poco ma sicuro
quel vestitino verde tista di merda fa
vincendo l'omesso nuovi do oggi
interroghiamo folletto vaio by you
bracci voi sì sì bimbo inutile della
minkia donna è partito e partite vince
ho vinto anch'io io che abbiamo vinto a
te culo
[Musica]
mi ha finito il salto in piscina e faqih
eh va beh eccolo ecco è questo si chiama
assalto del nord
ho fatto una cosa epica ecco ho preso
una bolla fantastico estate un figo
sembrati bomb altra o non non golf però
vediamo se riesco a farmi nata in regata
mica che mira di perché ciò il culo che
sembra quello di nicki minaj
[Musica]
siamo partiti bene dicono prendi anche
metti su oddio oddio no no no scherzavo
scherza cic ha risucchiato concesso
che bellissima coppia ragazza è pronto
youth tt vedo pronto sei nato pronto lo
so io che cazzo abbiamo combinato si
sono ancora vivo ma [ __ ]
devo capire un atc qualcuno di voi si
farà la domanda ma dove che c'era il
manubrio in questo momento e io ho
risposto e non della domanda
[Applauso]
cazzo ci sono perché sa testa mini torna
sempre indietro sono lei o lei
questo che fanno i golfisti quando per
non le parti io non lo so non lo sapevo
ragazzi cioè no al maltrattamento si
golfistici tipo
come suono obama e le sue medaglie
subito le voglia c'è un colpiti ragazzo
sono un camino sono kallio l'epicità se
non chi cazzo successo lega anche se non
ho capito cosa che babbo senza cipolla
stanza picanto calibro 45 magnum bribon
prenditela tuo zio non mi piace
chi va se prendiamo un caffè alcune
persone hanno il proprio accesso privato
ragazzi io sono una di quelle io non ce
la faccio senza io ho solo stimolo così
ok ok
guarda che [ __ ]
crema ho preso la ladra la quale c'ero
quasi nova bonobo minchia line il lancio
dei babbo
[Musica]
infatti effetti fagioli che ha mangiato
ieri vedo un giorno sì
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ha fatto alle 6 per fa vj cosa vuol dire
al lecce bene bene un mio livello nella
classifica mondiale di happy vis è così
ci faranno tutti un'idea della madonna
di chi sono sono convinto ci sono una
rock come fa ad avere si spalmi sottili
beh valli d'addio amico mio hai eolie o
yaoi a fiumana di malan ha schiacciato
lopresto e pelle è una soddisfazione
riuscire a prendere le anatre mi
chiamavano c'è chi cazzo la mancata
ragazzi sta cosa è lunga quasi quanto il
mio caso quanto il mio caro amico nonno
ciak che sta davanti qui che bello ma è
normale suo livello possono riuscire a
cadere dritto centra il buco una volta
nella tua vita
sì sì sì rivedere il mio didietro eccolo
sui fermenti questo è l'effetto che mi
fanno le donne se perché c'è una bambina
sotterrato sul soffitto ragazzino questo
può da questo polo mi stavano dire a
questo corpo giuro uscirà questo parco
papa dobbiamo andare l'ho fatta no ma
non ci crederò mai
veramente non l'ho capito ma chi come
cazzo stai pedalando zio
finché sono un fenomeno sei una merda
[Musica]
fa vj un milione nokia che ha fatto
questo milioni gestito milione ovunque
bello sa cos'è sta roba
9 beh bello mamma proprio bello si
eccolo lì perfetto ragazzi voli low cost
ma posso fare lega non è impossibile
guarda che ho beccato cosa sporca riga
verifiche e vittoria
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
questo episodio speciale di happiness un
pochettino diverso dal solito ma volevo
fare qualcosa di diverso
suo è più visto almeno quanto detto e
previsti questo cazzo di video concludo
pil episodio spero che vi sia piaciuto
come sento sei video è piaciuto al sotto
momento mi piace anche a madrid anche se
di facebook e come ogni video
trattandosi il pianeta se volessi
destinatari ci mettiamo un prossimo
video bella ragazza